salut et bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode des hols red les histoires à la
Belle-Mare c'est-à-dire on va raconter
quelque chose d'un peu incroyable d'un
peu exceptionnel qui vient du passé mais
il y aura pas forcément de gore à
l'intérieur là en l'occurrence on n'a
pas du tout aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter un escroc qui a réussi à se
faire un milliard de francs en l'espace
de 4 ans il a réussi à arnaquer tout le
monde y compris l'État français y
compris le président à tel point que
lorsque l'escroquerie a été révélé
l'État français a tout fait pour le
mettre un peu sous le tapis tellement
les gens avaient honte de aujourd'hui on
va parler des avions renifleurs de
pétrole juste avant de vous embarquer
dans cette aventure je veux absolument
préciser que cette vidéo n'est pas
sponsorisée voilà ça fait plaisir de le
dire par contre du coup je me to
sponsorise moi je fais un spectacle en
ce moment je suis un spectacle jusqu'au
mois de juin avec la tournée de mon
spectacle qui s'appelle archétype qui
mélange mentalisme science et mousse mon
quatrième spectacle France - Belgique
Suisse je vais partout et je serai le 22
novembre 2023 la salle Pleyel pour une
version très particulière de ce
spectacle si vous l'avez déjà vu vous
allez même pas le reconnaître et de mon
anniversaire vous avez les liens pour ça
dans la description je vous présente
Aldo Bonassoli mais qui est cet homme à
la base Aldo c'est un réparateur de
télévision mais dans le quotidien c'est
plutôt un inventeur et un inventeur
particulier un peu fantasque il a des
idées loufoques mais des grandes idées
par contre il a une cinquantaine
d'années il a un tempérament très
audacieux il est connu pour ça il fait
régulièrement des présentations de ses
inventions à la presse un jour par
exemple il invente un rayon qui est
désintégrateur de matière déjà rien
qu'avec ce premier élément je me dis
tiens si on se méfiait de lui ça
ressemble plus à un truc de cartoon le
rayon des intégrant qu'à un mec qui
répare des télés qui a inventé ça dans
son garage mais pourquoi pas tu mets à
lui d'y croire il convoque toute la
presse et il va leur faire une
démonstration de son rayon
désintégrateur de matière alors il va
faire disparaître deux casseroles des
petits objets divers en tout genre des
poupées de chiffon plein de trucs comme
ça évidemment tout le monde est étonné
mais il ne va pas s'arrêter là parce que
des inventions il en a on est un génie
on l'est pas peu de temps après Aldo
affirme qu'il un système qui permet
d'écouter ce qui se passe dans les
premiers satellites artificiels qu'on a
mis sur orbite c'est le début de la
conquête spatiale et Aldo a posé un
télescope sur son toit il l'a modifié il
l'a bricolé et il affirme qu'il peut
entendre ce qui se passe du coup dans
les satellites là-haut dans le ciel
alors il organise encore une grande
réunion où tout le monde vient il ramène
tout le monde il prévient qu'il va
capter des sons de la capsule spatiale
dans laquelle est enfermé le colonel
John Glyn qui est le premier américain à
avoir fait un vol orbital donc il y a un
moment donné la capsule spatiale va
passer au dessus de nous moi je vais
l'entendre parler il met ses écouteurs
il bidouille un peu sa machine sur
télescope et et à un moment donné
quelques minutes plus tard il fait c'est
bon ça y est j'ai tout entendu ça a
marché ça marchait et les rude de joie
petit souci il y a que lui qui a pu
entendre du coup puisqu'il était le seul
à avoir le casque et comme la capsule
est placée on peut plus réécouter Aldo
bonasoli quand même très discret sur les
composants qui forment sa machine sur
les procédés qui l'utilisent il se
montre très radin en termes
d'informations alors pour protéger aussi
des inventions mais même ces
explications elles ne vont jamais bien
loin comme si on n'était pas apte à le
comprendre au final Aldo affirme bien
plus souvent qu'il ne démontre il
affirme par exemple également pouvoir
désintégrer de l'essence à distance ce
qui entendent dire serait incroyable
pour stopper des chars des avions des
sous-marins des véhicules blindés de ce
genre de choses et puis toute manière en
cas de conflits aussi il a trouvé un
système pour désintégrer les bombes
atomiques à distance il a des solutions
à tout quand même entre deux réparations
de télé vous l'avez compris je me moque
gentiment lui mais c'est une sorte
d'arnaqueur il joue les apprentis
sorciers en permanence mais on n'a pas
de preuve que ce qu'il affirme on n'a
pas de preuve mais ça n'empêche pas des
gens d'y croire et c'est comme ça qu'il
va rencontrer un compte belge le compte
Alain de Villegas c'est quelqu'un de
respectable mais une cinquantaine
d'années qui habitent dans son château
en Belgique le compte est connu et se
présente d'ailleurs comme tel pour être
féru de science il adore la science et
quelqu'un de pragmatique c'est quelqu'un
qui aime les faits les preuves et qui
pensent que la science peut faire des
miracles par exemple il est persuadé en
séparant le sel de l'eau de mer on
pourra ensuite le transformer en or il
est aussi persuadé que l'an 2000 sera
l'année de l'Apocalypse alors ça il y en
a quand même beaucoup qui l'ont cru même
jusqu'à l'arrivée d'ailleurs de l'an
2000 et que seul certains humains seront
sauvés par les extraterrestres il est
faire une certaine science d'une science
merveilleuse d'une science un petit peu
magique et forcément le compte est
impressionné par bonne à Solier par
toutes ces inventions et ils croient
réellement ce qui fait pour bonasoli le
compte c'est la personne rêvée j'allais
dire le pigeon rêvé mais il y a un petit
peu de ça vous allez voir ils se sont
rencontrés ils ont sympathisés
maintenant on est en 1968 et il
s'associe pour développer une invention
de mon insolites ils vont créer un
détecteur de nappes d'eau profonde ce
qui coûte cher quand on cherche des
nappes d'eau alors c'est d'estimer ou
elle pourrait être mais c'est surtout le
forage après pour aller le constater
quand c'est un échec c'est un peu tout
ça pour rien et bien Aldo lui dit qu'il
a créé un détecteur il y a juste à le
développer ils vont le développer
ensemble ils vont aller le tester en
Bretagne ça marche très bien et ils vont
aller pousser ensuite leur détection en
Iran et dans le désert du Libier
également Aldo est très très fier que
les choses prennent vie qu'on en parle
qu'on commence aussi à le croire qu'on
le finance un petit peu d'ailleurs il
dit qu'il y a pas de limites à sa
détection qui peut détecter de l'eau à
n'importe quel profondeur peu importe la
quantité et d'ailleurs à partir de ce
moment-là Aldo va plus se présenter
comme comme inventaire ni même
d'ailleurs comme réparateur de télé mais
il va se présenter comme un professeur
en physique nucléaire bon peu importe
que ce diplôme n'existe pas lui il dit
qu'il l'a et de toute manière personne
ne demande à le voir personne ne lui
demande des comptes à ce sujet et ça
marche ça marche le fait d'aller faire
des recherches loin le fait d'être
associé à un compte belge ça marche à un
point qui vont avoir leur premier
investisseur et pas des moindres ça va
être carlopé samedi un riche ici homme
d'affaires italien qui va investir
l'équivalent de 70 millions d'euros dans
ce nouveau procédé incroyable Aldo avec
cet argent améliore son système et
prétend ensuite avoir trouvé une nappe
phréatique incroyable à 200 mètres de
profondeur en Espagne mais en plus de
cette nappe pratique allez dos et comme
un fou il saute de partout il parle à
tout le monde il est dans une excitation
folle grâce à tout cet argent il a
vraiment pu se consacrer à
l'amélioration du système et aujourd'hui
sans système ne détecte pas que les
nappes phréatiques non il détecte aussi
les nappes de pétrole et ça tombe plutôt
bien on est dans les années 70 et la
France vit son premier choc pétrolier
donc d'avoir tout un système qu'on peut
mettre dans un avion et que ces avions
puissent juste survoler une surface une
terre et détectée s'il y a du pétrole ou
pas c'est quand même pas mal deux donne
un nom à son appareil qu'on appellera
bien plus tard après dans la presse les
avions en hiver il appelle ça l'appareil
de détection à vision dirigée vds et là
ça va commencer à se transformer à la
Ocean seleven c'est à dire que beaucoup
de gens vont commencer à s'agglomérer
autour de notre ami Aldo le premier
c'est Jean violet j'ai en violet à la
base il travaille pour peace Andy celui
qui a investi les millions et les dans
l'affaire cet homme là est spécialisé en
exploitation de brevet d'invention il va
faire en sorte que cette invention
servent soit utile et connue il va en
parler à Philippe deweg c'est le
président de l'Union des banques suisses
UBS et l'UBS va offrir son soutien dans
toutes les transactions qui va y avoir à
réaliser mais Philippe de Wake veut
choisir ses partenaires il veut pas
n'importe qui autour de ce projet c'est
sûrement le projet du siècle pouvoir
détecter le pétrole à distance c'est
incroyable ça va donner longueur
d'avance et surtout des revenus assez
conséquents alors pour une invention
aussi révolutionnaire il veut une
société en béton la leader dans son
marché à l'époque il veut Elf le PDG de
Elf elle cette époque c'est Pierre
guillomard c'est un ancien ministre
Gauliste d'ailleurs et qui est très
embêté parce que ce qu'on est en pleine
crise pétrolière elle avait des
exploitations de pétrole en Irak et en
Algérie à les a toutes perdues ils sont
à leur recherche de nouveaux sites alors
vous pensez bien que quelqu'un qui
propose un avion qui est capable de
détecter depuis les airs en survolant
n'importe quel endroit du territoire qui
est capable donc de détecter du pétrole
mais aussi de l'uranium et du gaz parce
que ça ne s'arrête jamais avec Aldo
toujours plus et qu'on puisse connaître
les emplacements précis et les quantités
sans avoir besoin de faire de forage qui
est très intéressant pour les économies
d'argent de temps mais aussi pour la
discrétion bah dans le fond ça tout le
monde veut y croire c'est le bon moment
sauf que scientifiquement la détection
par infrarouge ça marche qu'en surface à
la limite à quelques mètres donc
personne ne sait comment ça marche
personne ne comprend pourquoi ça marche
mais tout le monde veille croire et
c'est comme ça que la machine commence à
se lancer et des années plus tard
d'ailleurs un des patrons de Elf enfin
des dirigeants de elfes dira simplement
dans une déclaration au début on s'est
dit bah pourquoi pas je sais c'est parti
d'un et pourquoi pas quand même ils
effectuent des tests dans le Tarn parce
que évidemment elle fait ne peut pas
partir à l'aveuglette ils envoient
l'avion l'avion détecte des nappes de
pétrole c'est gisement de pétrole ont
été aussi détectés par les techniciens
de chez elle il connaissaient
l'existence donc qui peuvent constater
que le système des détections
fonctionnent bien et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs Aldo et au taquet parce que
ça marche tout ça mais vous vous dites
si ça marche si bien pourquoi est-ce que
moi je le présente comme un escroc
depuis tout à l'heure c'est un moteur de
génie c'est là où il est très fort vous
avez vu que quand je vous raconte
l'histoire on a beau savoir que il y a
des choses qui sont bizarres au fur et à
mesure on a toujours le doute de est-ce
que là il a vraiment réussi à faire
quelque chose ou est-ce que tout ça
c'est du vent est-ce que vraiment sur la
base d'une fumisterie il irait aussi
loin alors je vais bien clair rien de ce
qu'il a inventé n'a fonctionné cet avion
renifleur c'est du vent ça n'existe pas
comment il a réussi à détecter les
bonnes nappes de pétrole dans le Tarn
bonassoly et vieégas avait eu les
relevés donc il y avait des fuites en
interne ils avaient eu accès en interne
chez ELF donc il savait déjà où est-ce
qui était les nappes sur la carte et ils
ont fait semblant de les découvrir tout
ça est fait sciemment et consciemment
sauf que évidemment tout le monde est
convaincu vous le savez mais moi je le
sais mais à l'époque il le savent pas
cinq jours plus tard le PDG le patron
PDF dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
va à l'Elysée pour annoncer la bonne
nouvelle au président de la République à
l'époque Valéry Giscard d'Estaing une
décision est prise on en parle à
personne pas un mot à la presse ça doit
rester complètement secret l'invention
est tellement révolutionnaire qu'il
faudrait pas se la faire piquer pour eux
l'invention de de Aldo et de vie légale
c'est une invention capable de renifler
le pétrole d'où le nom des avions
renouvelables tout se passe bien pour
Aldo ville et gaz continue d'investir il
crée un centre de recherche fondamental
le CRF dans son château directement en
Belgique ou son employé une vingtaine de
salariés donc il y a un labo il y a
plein d'ordinateurs à l'époque ça coûte
cher il y a des salariés on sait pas
très bien ce qu'ils font mais je vous
rappelle quand même que Villegas est
persuadé que en l'an 2000 on va tous
mourir que les extraterrestres nous
sauver et que si on récupère le sel qui
a dans la mer on peut le transformer en
or donc je suis pas sûr qu'ils sache
vraiment ce qu'il fait il achète
également un hangar de 2000 mètres
carrés situé sur l'aéroport militaire de
Bruxelles et il va y implanter le CER la
compagnie européenne de recherche quatre
avions un Boeing 7007 de ce pilotes et
30 personnes au sol il va aussi acheter
un bateau de prospection pétrolière
c'est énorme c'est 20 mètres de longueur
il va faire don également d'énormément
d'argent à des associations à des bonnes
œuvres avec autant d'argent investi de
la part de Villegas on peut que penser
que il est de bonne foi effectivement
tout a vraiment commencé il y a 8 ans
nous sommes maintenant en 1967 un avion
décolle depuis Ouessant dans le
Finistère pour survoler la mère d'Iroise
à son bord des personnes de chez ELF des
géologues évidemment le vds et Aldo au
décollage Aldo prévient les géologues il
dit vous pouvez regarder la machine si
vous voulez mais je vous préviens vous
allez pas comprendre donc ne cherchez
pas à comprendre l'avion vole un certain
temps au bout d'un moment le vds
commence à faire plein de bip un peu
bizarre sur les écrans il y a parfois
des grosses tâches noires qui
s'affichent et qui disparaissent elle
doit être comme un fou il regardait
c'est là c'est là c'est bon on a trouvé
effectivement comme prévu les géologues
ne comprennent rien du tout à ce qu'il
voit 1976 l'année où des membres de elfe
commence à avoir toutes c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qui qui vont faire ce test
comment savoir des doutes mais il
continue quand même d'y croire surtout
que quand même Aldo et vidéaste menace
de vendre leur invention aux Américains
ou à l'Irak ou à l'Algérie enfin au plus
offrant si jamais on ne les laissait pas
faire et qu'on commençait à mettre des
doutes sur la qualité de leur invention
donc tout le monde a vraiment très très
peur il y a un espèce de Fomo qui se
fait vous savez la peur de rater quelque
chose qui engendre comme ça un manque de
lucidité sur ce qui est en train de se
passer et donc ça continue ça continue à
minima pendant deux ans jusqu'au 24 juin
1978 où là il va y avoir la signature
d'un nouveau contrat avec l'État ce
contrat va allouer 500 millions de
francs suisses ça fait un peu plus de
470 millions d'euros aujourd'hui et ils
sont mis à disposition avec la
bénédiction du Premier ministre français
de l'époque Raymond Barre pourquoi tout
cet argent et à quoi il est censé servir
la moitié de cette somme est censée être
versée à Aldo en majeure partie en
grande partie pour comprendre le
fonctionnement du vds pour qu'il puisse
un peu libérer le fonctionnement de son
matériel et qui puisse imprimer
l'expliquer la deuxième moitié sera
versée à Aldo et à s'ils sont capables
de fournir dans l'année en cours c'est à
dire dans moins de 365 jours 10 millions
de tonnes de pétrole là on est sur du
concret la moitié pour qu'ils expliquent
comment fonctionne la machine l'autre
moitié si il livre 10 millions de tonnes
de pétrole et justement ça tombe bien
parce que Aldo dit que le vds a
découvert un beau gisement c'est un
gisement qui est censé être en Afrique
du Sud alors on en voit tout ce qu'il
faut pour commencer à faire le forage et
on fort et on fort et on force à
mobilise énormément de temps d'argent de
personnes forage comme ça on fort et on
sort toujours et on force jusqu'à 5900
mètres 5900 mètres la tige se coince
donc les ingénieurs d'Elf décident
d'arrêter les frais je vous cache pas
que Bona se lit est très très déçu
puisqu'il explique que c'est vraiment
dommage parce que le la nappe se trouve
à 62002 mètres là c'est avant il avait
pas encore la donnée mais maintenant on
est sûr il n'était qu'à 300 mètres c'est
dommage entre temps elle va changer de
PDG c'est Alain Chalandon maintenant qui
est le président le directeur général de
Elf le président de la France est
toujours Valéry Giscard d'Estaing et les
deux communiquants entre eux et commence
vraiment avoir des gros doutes sur ce
qui se passe on pourrait dire que Aldo
commencerait à lever le pied un petit
peu sur ses affaires et son arnaque mais
pas du tout pour lui ça ne fait que
commencer c'est l'autoroute de la
connerie continue le 5 avril 1979 Aldo
invite Chalandon donc le PDG de Elf est
Valérie Giscard d'Estaing alors
rejoindre dans une petite cabane en
Champagne-Ardenne parce que ils veulent
leur montrer quelque chose il va faire
apparaître un objet dans un écran grâce
à des résonances magnétiques vous savez
pas ce que ça veut dire moi non et pour
être honnête Aldo non plus de retour à
l'Élysée Valéry Giscard d'Estaing va
écrire une note très négative sur Aldo
et sur ce qu'il a vu dans la cabane et
sur ses impressions il va écrire ça sa
secrétaire dans le but de laisser une
trace écrite quelque part moins de deux
mois après le 24 mai 1979 le ministre de
l'Industrie de l'époque va rapatrier
tout le matériel qui avait chez vilégias
ou le matériel scientifique et il va
nommer à la tête de ce projet là un
scientifique de renom c'est Jules
eurovitz qui est désigné et qui va
devoir vérifier le bien-fondé de toute
cette affaire elle donne pas très peur
et il y a pas de problème vous voulez
contrer c'est la qualité de mon bébé DS
on va le tester c'est fou que vous
remettiez ça en cause mais il y a pas de
souci on va mettre le vds dans une pièce
on va mettre un énorme mur devant lui et
vous derrière ce mur vous allez placer
voilà prenez cette règle vous allez
placer cette règle là derrière et nous
on constatera sur mes écrans qu'on voit
la forme de la règle apparaître comme ça
vous serez convaincu au moins que c'est
capable de détecter même s'il y a des
choses comme ça qui qui empêchent la
vision censée être infrarouge donc c'est
ce qui se passe orovit ne reste pas du
côté de du vds lui dit où je vais aller
du côté de la règle pour voir qu'il y a
pas d'engouilles en fait de l'autre côté
du mur et puis le reste des équipes qui
sont là pour le vérification reste avec
Aldo du côté du vds Aldo enclenche le
VDS
quatre ans et à écouter environ un
milliard de francs mais la ferme
n'éclate pas au grand jour pourquoi
parce que c'est un peu comme l'histoire
que je vous avais raconté en 2016 ou
2017 il me semble sur sur la chaîne sur
celui qui avait vendu la Tour Eiffel et
plusieurs fois en plus un autre escroc
parce que les gens ont honte ils ont
honte de parce que on parle de grandes
entreprises on parle de l'État on parle
du Président on parle d'un Premier
ministre ils veulent pas que que tout le
monde sache qu'ils se sont fait
pigeonner mais très bêtement je veux
dire personne n'avait ne serait-ce que
vérifié la machine ou démonter pour la
remonter sans savoir comment elle
fonctionne mais déjà pour regarder un
petit peu ce qu'il y avait aucun test
probant n'avait été effectué quelque
chose de critique vis-à-vis des
possibilités de la machine deux ans plus
tard en 1981 changement de président
c'est la gauche qui prend le pouvoir
avec Mitterrand qui arrive aux commandes
on fait un petit tour dans les comptes
et on trouve que il y a des choses qui
sont bizarres qu'on n'arrive pas à
comprendre dans ces contes là au début
ça fait pas énormément de bruit des
recherches ont été effectuées des
questions vont être posées et en 1983
l'affaire éclate au grand jour en plus
de ça pour le nouveau parti pour la
gauche qui a pris le pouvoir c'est un
plaisir de pouvoir taper sur la droite
qui était là avant la réalité c'est
qu'on sait pas déjà où est passé tout le
frais tout le pognon tout cet argent
alors on sait qu'il y en a une partie
qui est passé dans le château de
villelegas dans le personnel dans dans
le matériel qu'ils avaient acheté mais
ça représente pas tout l'argent qui a
été donné on est sûr aussi d'autres
choses c'est que Aldo n'a pas touché lui
à titre personnel tant d'argent que ça
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il y a des
théories qui disent que c'est maître
violet souvenez-vous maître violet c'est
celui qui a qui a intégré en fait l'état
à tout ce système qui aurait ponctionné
et qui aurait des via maximum d'argent
il n'y a pas vraiment de preuve encore
aujourd'hui en 2023 ça ça reste très
chaud il y aura pas de poursuite face à
tout ça il y aura pas de procès non plus
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing va rendre
public la note confidentielle qu'il
avait fait à sa secrétaire note qui
disait qu'il avait des doutes et qui
craignait d'être en face de d'escroc et
d'arnaqueurs donc ça ça va le dédouaner
en 1984 bonasoly va même aller jusqu'à
donner une interview dans son
laboratoire pour défendre son travail
cette interview on peut la retrouver sur
le site de l'image je vous mettrai un
lien dans la description pour bonne
insoli son seul employeur c'était
Villegas donc il touchait son salaire de
la part de vie légale et c'est tout et
quand on regarde son train de vie on
peut se dire qu'apparemment il a pas
gagné effectivement tant d'argent que ça
ville les gars lui qui devait rendre
tout l'argent et décédé ruiner quelques
années plus tard quant à Aldo il est il
est revenu à son point de départ il est
redevenues réparateur de télévision
comment ça peut fonctionner une affaire
d'une telle ampleur je pense que c'est
vraiment les mécaniques psychologiques
là qui rentrent en ligne de compte la
première chose en fait c'est de
dissocier deux faisceaux de distorsion
de la réalité la première distorsion de
la réalité c'est c'est celui qui s'auto
convaincre qu'il a créé quelque chose et
on a un gros problème psychologique chez
Aldo qui vit un peu dans un rêve moi je
suis pas persuadé que que soit un
arnaqueur dans le sens où il cherche
absolument
à s'enrichir on a des preuves qu'il a
pas gagné tant que ça il aurait pu il
aurait pu trouver un système il est
malin on a surtout à faire un mythomane
un peu rêveur un peu fantasque j'aime
croire que il savait que ces inventions
marchaient pas ça c'est sûr qu'il
arrivait à se convaincre ensuite qu'elle
fonctionnait et qui se disait dans le
temps je vais trouver c'est qu'une
affaire de temps et qui vivait en fait
son moment maintenant en se disant mais
je vais trouver la solution pour faire
ça plus tard de manière c'est sûr c'est
possible la deuxième distorsion de la
réalité c'est les autres c'est les
autres qui bénéficient de des avions
renifleurs en l'occurrence parce que
cette solution elle répondait en fait à
un besoin c'était le besoin de pétrole
de l'époque on avait tellement envie d'y
croire que du coup on met sur OFF ces
signaux d'esprit critique les biais
cognitifs prennent le relais et par
exemple en psychologie il y a quelque
chose qui est très connu en manipulation
c'est le besoin de cohérence on va avoir
du mal à revenir en arrière soi-même
pour son intégrité mentale en fait la
dissonance cognitive c'est très dur de
prendre le recul et de dire je me suis
trompé et puis il y a un billet naturel
d'autorité plus les personnes qui
participent au projet sont des personnes
qui pèsent dans le game plus elles vont
convaincre de leur aura ça va dégager
une espèce DALO que tout essaye à partir
du moment où Waldo c'est Maquet un petit
peu avec quand même un compte belge qui
possède un château c'est ça qui a permis
en fait à mettre au violet qui
connaissait et qui avait ses accès à
l'état qui connaissaient réagis car
destin d'en parler à la présidence la
présidence à la reporté sa confiance sur
le mec qui lui apporte l'affaire parce
qu'elle le connaît bien elle voit aussi
qu'il y a un gros investisseur italien
entre temps avec quand même plusieurs
millions à la clé que tout ça échapoté
par un compte en Belgique donc ça
paraissait if on se dit à chaque fois en
fait lui il a vérifié et ça c'est
vraiment le propre de l'homme c'est à
dire que à chaque fois qu'il y a
plusieurs personnes qui sont capables de
faire une action pour vérifier ou pour
aider tout le monde va se dire
intérieurement l'eau de va le faire
c'est malheureusement ce qui explique
les cas d'agression par exemple dans le
métro ou quelqu'un se progresser au
couteau et se fait dépouiller par
exemple et personne ne bouge dans le
wagon et nous on se dit moi si j'avais
été là ça serait pas passé comme ça
j'aurais bougé en réalité c'est parce
qu'il y a plein de monde que personne a
bougé parce que chacun se sentait
responsabilisé en se disant les autres
vont faire quelque chose voilà comment
la faire des avions renifleurs a pu
perdurer quatre ans je trouve ça
incroyable j'adore vous aviez en
commentaire je sais que c'est pas une
histoire qui est très très connue mais
moi je la connaissais depuis longtemps
je me suis dit que ça rentrait bien
comme ça dans dans ce format de vidéo
donc j'ai hâte d'avoir vos retours je
vous mets aussi toutes les anciennes
histoires comme ça que j'ai pu raconter
dans la description évidemment la même
description vous trouvez les dates de
tournée pour venir me voir un spectacle
on se voit à la fin du spectacles si
vous avez envie de m'attendre après le
show 10 minutes après je sors et on peut
papoter faire des photos tout ça prenez
soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao